tras una gran inestabilidad política en
perú el presidente pedro castillo ha
iniciado un nuevo capítulo en su
gobierno que ha terminado con el
nombramiento de siete nuevos ministros y
que comenzó con la renuncia de guido
bellido ex primer ministro del país
informó al país que el día de hoy
hemos aceptado la renuncia del
presidente del consejo de ministros
guido bellido ugarte a quien le
agradezco por sus servicios prestados a
la nación la renuncia de bellido
simpatizante del grupo terrorista
sendero luminoso supone un
distanciamiento del mandatario con el
ala más radical del gobierno desde su
juramentación dos meses atrás bellido
tuvo disputas recurrentes en el congreso
y siempre nuestra nuestro cargo a
disposición está en la mesa del
presidente
y el presidente de la toma de decisión
de acuerdo a sus convicciones de acuerdo
a sus criterios políticos que tiene
uno cuando asume esta responsabilidad no
puede preguntar de por qué
o como
simplemente uno tiene que cumplir
todo lo que está enmarcado
en la constitución ahora el presidente
ha remodelado su gobierno con una carta
más moderada con el nombramiento de
mirtha vásquez política ambientalista de
izquierdas como nueva primera ministra
junto a seis nuevos ministros con los
que ha pasado de dos a cinco mujeres en
el ejecutivo una estrategia con la que
castillo espera lograr más consenso para
sacar adelante sus iniciativas